well hopes of rescuing five men on board
a missing submersible are fading as
their oxygen supply is expected to have
run out by now a multinational effort to
locate The Vessel continues around the
wreckage of the Titanic some 600
kilometers off the coast of Newfoundland
Canada the crew of the Titan lost
contact with its support ship on Sunday
the 96-hour oxygen supply on the vessel
was expected to run down by 10 GMT on
Thursday
Gabrielle Elizondo is in Boston where
the U.S Coast Guard is helping with the
search and Gabriel what's the latest on
the search and rescue mission
well at this very hour there are
remotely operated deep diving devices uh
that are scouring the bottom of the
ocean in and around where the wreckage
of the Titanic is located these are rovs
remotely operated Vehicles as they're
called one is brought it has been
brought in from France another one from
Canada it took them several days to get
here and they are specialized uh uh a
deep dive equipment that feedback a
video signal live to a boat at the
surface where people can control them
and get a look at exactly in real time
uh what's going on at the bottom of the
sea down there more than three
kilometers below this the ocean's
surface so perhaps
today we will be getting some more
information on if they see any remains
at all of the missing Titan submersible
but as of right now it's still a very
much an international search and rescue
operation involving the American Coast
Guard Canadians and French but so far
they have found no signs of the
submersible now that the oxygen is
expected to have run out on the sub I
think five hours ago is there any talk
at all about calling off the search
effort
well that's a very delicate uh question
that has been asked of the Coast Guard
and as of now they are saying no that uh
they say that if there's any hope at all
even the slightest hope that they might
find the submersible and the people on
on board alive they're going to continue
this search and rescue operation uh
however the reality is this has been
since Sunday now that they've been
searching so it's what going on four and
a half almost almost five days now the
oxygen the reserve Oxygen by all
accounts is run out so at some point
probably in the coming days you would
think the Coast Guard is going to make
this not a search and rescue but perhaps
a search and Recovery Mission
acknowledging that the chance of
survival has gone to zero okay thank you
so much that is Gabrielle Elizondo for
us in Boston